the scp foundation contains a lot of
monsters from scp-682 the lizard that
refuses to die to
scp-939 a species of pack hunters that
steal the voices of their victims the
dangerous predators that occupy the
hundreds of containment cells of the
foundation make it their job to hunt and
kill innocent people or worse but have
you ever wondered where some of those
monsters come from the first encounter
that the scp foundation had with
scp-4049 was on july 14th of 2010. the
foundation operates a massive
surveillance network around the entire
world through the use of ai delegated
duties and compartmentalized information
they're able to have 9-1-1 operators
report any calls that seem anomalous in
nature while knowing nothing about the
foundation itself this way they're able
to constantly be aware of anything
anomalous going on in the country that
gets reported to 9-1-1 on july 14th the
foundation was alerted of a call that
likely had an anomalous component at
first it didn't seem like much it was a
remote address in wyoming outside of a
small town called gardnerville the
vacation home of one richard sampson a
wealthy businessman in the area placed
right on the slopes the call was made
late in the afternoon by someone
purporting to be the groundskeeper of
the home while mr samson was away he was
screaming into the phone terrified and
largely incoherent but the operator made
out something about a monster attacking
the house there was a lot of noise in
the background sounds of shouting
destruction and what sounded like
animalistic roars and grunts the 911
operator moved the call up and it didn't
take long for the foundation to
determine that something strange was
going on here they dispatched a handful
of agents deep undercover as officers
with the wyoming highway patrol to the
address of the home where the call had
come from after about half an hour the
agents called back into hq the scene
they had found was nothing short of
gruesome upon arrival they were greeted
with what appeared to be the aftermath
of a particularly violent and brief
tornado the entire front section of the
ground floor had been shredded the
gardens trampled and the interior
utterly destroyed the agents picked
their way between the wreckage of the
home it functionally didn't exist
anymore the walls were collapsed from
being rammed and torn through and the
roof had collapsed in on itself the
broken shards and pieces of furniture
and wreckage were everywhere despite
appearances this wasn't a tornado a
tornado would have thrown the entire
house around no
this was as the groundskeeper had said
something alive monstrous and very angry
speaking of the groundskeeper the
foundation agents began to look for him
once they took stock of the damage of
the home at first they couldn't find him
among the massive pieces of debris and
assume the worse even if whatever had
destroyed the house decided to not kill
him he could easily have been killed by
the collapsing house buried under rubble
or a dozen other things they picked
through the ruins calling out that they
were from the police and were here to
help eventually after another half hour
of searching they heard something what
sounded like crying and whispering
became audible as the wind died down the
agents honed in on the noise and found
it was coming from one of the larger
piles of rubble after getting some
equipment they were able to heft up the
piece of the collapsed roof and found
the groundskeeper underneath curled into
a ball and talking to himself he seemed
to be in some kind of panicked fugue
state not responding to the agents
trying to get through to him they
wrapped him in a shock blanket and put
him in the back of one of their patrol
cars but even after that they couldn't
get anything of use out of him he was
just shaking and muttering something
about monsters eventually he was given
amnestics to forget about the incident
entirely and recovered after the agents
reported back to hq a new issue popped
up they weren't the only ones who knew
about this a news website a few counties
away had the story the foundation
quickly put out a cover story the house
had probably been destroyed by a group
of grizzly bears possibly rabid they had
the local government issue a warning
advising local residents to stay inside
and out of the wilderness until the
animals could be tracked and euthanized
and that's exactly what the foundation
did mobile task force epsilon 6 the
village idiots an mtf that specializes
in taking on anomalous threats in remote
rural areas and small towns were
dispatched to track and contain or
terminate whatever had destroyed that
mansion the creature had left a strong
trail of tracks scent and general
destruction and the troopers followed it
north for hours into another dense
forest where they discovered the
gigantic hulking creature while was
asleep and shot it it was huge with
rippling muscles on all four legs and no
fur to speak of but the most striking
feature was a frighteningly human face
the agents resolved to let the
researchers handle the autopsy and busy
themselves with the other things in that
forest there was an old abandoned arms
factory that the creature seemed to have
come from the agents descended into the
decrepit abandoned building following
the creature's trail right into the
basement there they found a large steel
door and behind it the anomaly that
would eventually be called scp-4049
it was strange it seemed to be some kind
of massive empty room looking up into
the sky even though they were deep
underground not entirely empty the dirt
ground had a series of concentric rings
of gravestones in it all facing inward
the agents were treated once they
realized they had walked into a spatial
anomaly and called for backup the
foundation quickly flew in researchers
and a containment team to figure out
what the anomaly was and to ensure no
one else got into the factory while they
figured that out the basement of the
factory became a sort of base of
operations for the large crew of
research and security personnel assigned
to
scp-4049 after making sure there were no
other of the monsters designated
scp-4049-1 instances in the nearby
forest the researchers began to
experiment on it they determined that
the room on the other side of the
hallway was in an extra dimensional
space members of d-class personnel were
sent in with gps trackers and even
though they could still be heard fine on
the radio the gps trackers failed
totally obviously the fact that you
could see the sky from an underground
room was anomalous but attempts to dig
into where the room should have been
from the surface also led to nothing but
more dirt from inside the d-class were
able to give a detailed report on the
room as they walked around it was
perfectly circular and pretty large
about 30 feet across give or take a tall
white wall ringed the room's border and
was perfectly smooth and impossible to
get a grip on enough to climb cold hard
marble the floor of the room wasn't
marble though it seemed to be regular
dirt the d-classes were ordered by
researchers to get samples of what they
could and they scooped a little dirt
into sample bags but as soon as the
subjects stepped back over the threshold
into the corridor of scp-4049
the sample bags they collected
spontaneously combusted going up in
flames any chemical analysis of its
composition was of course impossible the
researchers resolved to get what
information they could of just looking
at scp-4040
first and there was still a lot to look
at the d-class inspected the rings of
gravestones inside scp-4049
there were just two at the moment a
larger ring contained a smaller ring
inside the smaller ring there was a
circular empty space a few feet wide
most of the graves were unfilled and
unmarked just a patch of dirt turned
over but about a dozen of them had a
gravestone at their head made of that
same white marble substance the walls
were made from they weren't fancy just a
simple white rectangle stamped with some
strange symbols the d-class took photos
and sent them to the researchers who
recognized the markings as an ancient
word in greek hound the researchers were
admittedly baffled by what this could
mean for scp-4049
but decided to figure out the connection
using the evidence they had the corpse
of the scp-4049-1
instance the researchers placed the huge
corpse inside the factory creating a
secure space to perform the autopsy then
a team of doctors began cutting into it
with scalpels or they tried anyway they
quickly realized that the skin of the
creature was far too thick to be
breached with scalpels and resorted to
long sharpened knives they discovered
quite a few things about the instance's
anatomy along with why and how it was
able to do and absorb so much damage it
was a quadruped walking on four limbs
the forward one seemed to be in the
shape of arms with elbows and wrists but
also had clawed paused like a dog's the
back legs were thick and heavily muscled
and digit degrade again just like a dog
so they could be used to leap and jump
great distances once they cut away the
skin the researchers noticed that it was
indeed much thicker than they expected
it to be human skin is only about two
millimeters thick but this was a full
centimeter throughout as well as
incredibly tough and gaming internally
the structure was all wrong it seemed
almost human-like but with a few key
differences to suit the vastly changed
exterior body the spine was much thicker
and wider as well as being curved to fit
the four-legged structure there seemed
to be redundant organs the researchers
theorized they were backups like the
secondary heart they found inside the
creature's innards it could serve as a
backup if the main heart stopped working
or was damaged or it could work together
with the main heart to improve the
instance's performance during physical
activity there didn't seem to be any
kind of reproductive system it wasn't
surgically removed it just wasn't there
at all like it had magically disappeared
and inside the thing's head the skull
was different the mouth was much wider
and larger and it didn't take long for
the researchers to figure out why when
rooting around in its mouth they quickly
discovered it had an extra set of sharp
teeth behind its main set all unnerving
slightly disturbing discoveries but the
most frightening wasn't something they
found inside the instance it was
something they noticed immediately upon
containing it its face was human it had
been morphed of course to fit the
altered skull but there were two eyes a
forehead a nose
lips it was inarguably a human face
while the researchers sent for a dna
test they were disturbed but not
surprised to discover what they had
already been expecting the instance was
entirely genetically human not a changed
species or close relative this creature
had once been a regular human being like
you or i the researchers had just sent
the dna sample off to check if there was
a match in the criminal database when
suddenly the lights went red the doors
sealed and the sight's alarms began to
sound at that moment the steel door
leading to scp-4049 flung open and
another
scp-4049-1 instance bounded out into the
corridor on all fours it set its beady
eyes on three members of the mobile task
force standing on the far side of the
long corridor for a moment it didn't do
anything and it let out a long screech
that echoed around the entire factory
its rear legs tensed up and it began to
bound down the hallway toward them all
the security guards opened fire with
their machine guns on the anomaly trying
to bring it down it shrugged off the
bullets like they were raindrops and
didn't so much as slow down meanwhile
the two dozen other security personnel
in the facility were rapidly grabbing
their weapons and armor from their
lockers before rocketing down the stairs
to the corridor by the time they made it
down it was too late the instance was
using its claws and jaws to tear two of
the three poor members of the task force
to shreds it wasn't eating them but it
was attacking them with enough anger and
malice that there wasn't going to be
much left when it was done the third
member of the task force had fallen and
was backing away from the anomaly in
fear the remaining members of the task
force opened fire smothering the
scp-4049-1 instance in a hail of bullets
the sudden overwhelming firepower caught
it off guard and after a few seconds of
sustained gunfire it fell to the ground
dead once the foundation realized the
active danger that scp-4049 presented
they decided not to take any chances
with containment the 50-meter long
corridor leading to scp-4049 from the
basement elevator was fortified an
airlock was installed on the far side
separating it from the rest of the
factory then motion detectors were set
every few meters throughout the hallway
attached to a series of deterrents if an
scp-4049-1 instance smashed out of the
steel door it would trip the alarms and
activate everything from a supersonic
sound cannon to sentry guns and a
machine gun emplacement and if none of
those worked the entire corridor could
be pumped full of nerve gas guaranteeing
the death of the instance without
risking the lives of any personnel this
kill corridor was to be guarded by the
applied task force iota 9 to ensure that
no scp-4049-a
instance would survive its escape but
after the corridor was retrofitted the
foundation had a bigger problem where
were these scp-4049-1
instances coming from to begin with they
performed another dna test on the new
instance its face was different so it
seemed logical that it was a different
person when the results came back the
researchers were surprised to find that
not just one but both of the samples had
dna matches in the national database
both were men from the tri-state area
who had mysteriously died or disappeared
in the past few months while at some
kind of religious service they were both
avid big game hunters with an interest
in shooting moose bears and elk and most
important they had both been the subject
of a fire-related incident one had been
presumed dead when his house burned down
the other had simply vanished with this
car being found hours later on fire by
the side of a highway in both cases a
body was never recovered but the
authorities did find a strange
stone-tipped arrow driven into the
ground nearby over the following months
the foundation observed a number of
these strange events happening in
wyoming idaho and montana and like
clockwork every time it happened a new
headstone appeared over one of the
previously unmarked graves inside
scp-4049 saying the same greek word
hound on top of all of that almost every
time a man in the area disappeared under
these specific circumstances and a grave
was created an
scp-4049-1 instance would appear inside
scp-4049 sometime in the following two
months buried within the soil circle in
the center of the room he would claw its
way out of the dirt smash open the steel
door to scp-4049
and race down the hallway trying to kill
and destroy whatever was in front of it
until it was gunned down but in one
instance that didn't happen on september
17th of 2015 the foundation had gotten
into the rhythm of containing scp-4049
so they weren't startled or caught off
guard when an agent with the highway
patrol reported finding a flaming truck
near a hunting ground in the bed was an
elk carcass with a stone tipped arrow
lodged deep into the meat applied task
force iota 9 at the factory began to
prepare for an imminent appearance from
an scp-44
entity within the following weeks and
established a round-the-clock guard in
the kill corridor but it never came by
december nothing had happened at all the
foundation made the decision a d-class
would be sent into scp-4049 with a
camera and radio in the hopes of
manually initiating the event to occur
the d-class subject wasn't given very
specific instructions just fitted with a
body camera a two-way radio and told to
listen to all instructions on the
headset the researchers ordered him
forward until he reached the other side
of the hallway where he was to open the
steel door leading to scp-4049
and enter when he entered everything
looked the same as the foundation
expected it to the same gravestones
walls and dirt he moved towards the
center of the room to the dirt circle
but suddenly stopped looking around when
the researchers asked why he reported
hearing the sound of dogs barking for a
moment before the researchers told him
to keep walking when he stopped in the
center of the room he again radioed in
feeling that someone was there the
camera didn't pick anyone up but he
insisted that there was an odd feeling
just before the audio stream suddenly
cut out a burst of static interference
drowned everything else out and was
slowly winded down
the d-class couldn't be heard anymore
but a strange female voice was on the
line
speaking to the foundation she mentioned
that the foundation had been ruining her
pets for far too long the foundation
demanded the speaker identify themselves
but she just scoffed indignant at what
she called human arrogance right after
that all audio feeds were cut out
permanently this mysterious woman was
designated as scp-4049-2
seven seconds after they cut out the
largest scp-44
instance ever recorded exited scp-4049
standing at almost 11 meters high all of
the deterrents were activated but even
then it still took all of them combined
with machine gun fire from the applied
task force to bring the creature down no
remains of the d-class and no traces of
whoever was speaking on the radio were
ever found by the researchers it can be
dangerous to stand between someone and
their beloved pets now go watch
scp-1437 a whole to another place and
scp-087 the stairwell for more extra
dimensional spaces from scp explained